ladies you guys are so hot you'll touch
your own body parts in bed you're on top
like oh yeah no guy wants to touch
himself no guy's like hey all right
yeah because I think you're more turned
on by men's skills ladies and our actual
looks whereas men we're all visual we go
to a strip club we're like Yeah dance on
that pole at a Female Strip Club it's
more like yeah install that pole okay
and you're so damn mysterious ladies we
have no idea what turns you on you know
everything that turns us on we don't
know what the hell you gals like I asked
my wife I was like what turns you on she
goes I like a man who listens I don't
know I tuned out
I don't know I'm not a big strip club
guy I'm too awkward I'm not cool some
guys are good at strip clubs they know
what to say they're getting a lap dance
they're like yeah or whatever I
don't know I'm too awkward I was in the
back room once getting a private dance
the ladies grinding me she's like so
what do you do I'm like well I'm a
comedian she goes ooh tell me a joke I
was like well look I'm not at work you
are
she didn't like that joke